hey everybody and welcome to a
triumphant wild ride with stevo it
doesn't get much more triumphant than
simultaneously being the champion of the
world in two different
weight divisions in the ufc like this
week's guest daniel cormier man i love
this guy i'm such a fan and
i mean what an honor to have him plus we
get into it it gets juicy
his
ongoing beef with jon jones man couldn't
believe what i was hearing out of the
guy it's crazy and if any two people
know about getting beat up it's me and
daniel cormier he knows a little more
about beating other people up but all
the same when it comes to a night's
sleep we need to take care of our
precious bodies man and you know how i
do that with my mattress from helix
sleep.com
i love my mattresses from helixsleep.com
i have them on my bed at my house on my
bed on my tour bus on my bed in my
warehouse
dude every bed i have is decked out with
mattresses from helixsleep.com because
they are that good why are they that
good because they're customized for you
specifically you go to helixsleep.com
you take a very quick and easy two
minute quiz to match you up with the
perfect mattress for you
and your partner if you have two people
sleeping in bed i'm telling you it's the
best plus if you go to helix sleep.com
stevo then automatically you're gonna
get up to two hundred dollars off of any
mattress you buy
and you'll get two free pillows with it
what a deal what a great company and
there is no risk whatsoever because you
get to try this mattress for a full 100
nights and if you don't love it you get
your money back plus they will pick it
up for you but take it from me you're
gonna love it so go to helixsleep.como
right now and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen daniel cormier my
bad dude people how are you doing dude
i'm great man what an honor to have you
um
and and thank you man like we get to do
each other's podcast so
uh if you're listening to this one first
go straight
to two years what's that one called do
you have like a million dollars we're
just starting it like we're just
starting it's called multifaceted
because everybody kind of sees me as the
fighter right but there's so many
different levels to who i am you know i
was outside of the commentary in the
fight game but like i love everything i
love i mean outside of sports you know
like video games and and comic books and
all kinds of other shits i want to show
that side of myself i i love it man i
love it and uh you know i think
that i yeah i'm driving over here like
just
i'm so impressed by
all of the commentators for the ufc yeah
you know i mean the way like is it just
so satisfying when you're breaking down
what's going on in a fight and you're
like okay now
he's gonna move over onto his left hip
he's gonna you know like with and and
precisely what you say is exactly what
unfolds you know it's it's kind of crazy
because when i first started
i would do that and it would happen a
lot as i've gotten a little bit further
away from competing it doesn't happen as
much on point now tony romo was going
through the same stuff romo would say oh
this guy's in the cover 2 defense you're
going to look for him to go to number 82
over here but you got to remember romo
was in quarterback meetings six months
prior just as i was in the gym every
single day so i could kind of see what
was going to happen but as you get away
from it you're less accurate with those
predictions as to what's happening i
think you're giving yourself a heart
attack
it's always fascinating when you're like
oh he's got it he's got the lock he's
like he always taps as soon as you guys
commit to that sometimes sometimes you
get you get excited you know me and
rogan both i'm like it's over it's over
yeah it didn't happen or it doesn't
happen like it's like it's fun right
it's it's it's a great job man and
you know we we're we're calling the
fights and we see you guys out there and
you guys are like geeking up out the
whole time you're just geeking dude i
love it i love it man i'm there when the
seats are empty i didn't i can't believe
how early you show up
we were in maui yesterday and he's at
the at the poolside bar watching the ufc
fight
at the poolside bar that was two days
ago but yeah
yeah this god says man dana white loves
you dude you're here on vacation just
like buried in the ipad watching the
video you know it's crazy though it's
like it's like you're watching and
you're not watching the greatest fight
card these are fight cards that if
you're gonna kind of pack it in for one
maybe it's this one but i don't mess up
you don't miss them i don't i watch them
all and one of your former opponents was
in the main event
[Laughter]
that really was awful man what's
what we got to do with the judging so so
steve so so here's the thing steve
i made a video yesterday on my youtube
and i spoke about the unjust
judging and how even for a guy like me
that has done all this is so confused as
to what i'm watching because i got it
wrong but then a smart man named ben
cartlitch this guy from england he sends
me all these criteria so here's what he
told me
if holly holm
has control for three minutes and 45
seconds well i mean she had over 10
minutes
over five minutes but in that round say
round three which is essentially what it
came down to if you and i are fighting
steve and i'm like holding you up
against the side of the octagon and i
push you in and i'm winning and then you
get me with a good shot because that
in that damage outweighs control
that essentially is what the rounds
should be judged on
which is absurd
but
that's like i guess that's the judging
criteria you know that's how the
criterias were do you think there should
be more than three judges
i think i think that would just cause
more confusion if three can't get it
right like i think it's one judge let's
go to one judge right think about that
go to one person decide who wins the
fight because when you do three like one
somebody has like
fights are like it's 49 46 one guy
48 47 one then 48 47 the other one so
it's like
nobody's watching the same fight right
that home fight was a good example
because one judge had it 30 27 yeah and
then the other two out of 29 28.
um
it's just insanity now i saw your tweet
after that fight and you said oh i got
it wrong
like that's pretty
you know that's taking the high road
yeah and saying you got it wrong because
i think that that the entire world oh
yes you want that the top hollywood yeah
you know it was like first off the uh
jung young park beat eric anders and i
was like oh eric anders won the fight
and then
jung young park one i was like well i
was wrong john young park one right
that's right
wrong again i go wrong again i mean i
guess i don't know what i'm watching you
know it's like it's a it's a weird and i
saw ariel tweeted
after that card that
he he now cannot think of any reason why
any fighter would not want open scoring
yeah meaning that
as you go into each round it's it's
announced like what the the scorecards
read yeah i don't i don't i don't agree
actually i don't like open scoring i
don't like the idea of open scoring i
really don't i think that if you do so
all right steve you're not a guy that
likes to like play it safe
okay right but if you go
uh after the first round uh it's it's
ten nine stevo second round 2018 stevo
you're like yo all i got to do is not
get knocked out so now you're so safe
right through five minutes it becomes
not a good fight
it's like then you're so safe because
but then it also puts the the pressure
on the other guy
yeah
i mean i think that you gotta always
assume especially now
that
that you have to
win all you know like you gotta you get
you can't ever assume that you're they
used to always say don't leave it in the
hands of the judges and everybody's like
that's a lot easier to say than it is to
do but like
now you should not leave it in the hands
of the judges because it's so
inconsistent like yeah it's too
inconsistent yeah do you miss do you
miss fighting
you know on days like this because today
was the seven year anniversary when i
won my first title right i beat anthony
johnson on
uh i don't know if today's the 23rd
yesterday at 23.
yeah may 23rd 2015. right so then i
started getting like just all this like
on this date and i see myself walking
out and there's like me in the back
before fighting i'm like wow it takes
you back to that moment right and
there's no moment like that like no
matter what i do in this life like
nothing will ever match
walking out oh dude it's like it's like
the greatest like if there's a drug in
the world that was like the most amazing
there's nothing like it ever because
when you're back there
so there's like stages so you leave your
hotel and it's like all day long you're
like doing [ __ ] to try to occupy
yourself from remembering that someone
wants to kill you
kick your ass tonight
that's crazy right so get into a fight
like it's whatever like i got into a
fight with a guy but like because it
happens right there there's no time to
think about it well these championship
fights which i fought ten straight to
end my career right
i've got 12 weeks to think of a guy that
wants to kill me the toughest baddest
guy
so all day you're like trying to keep
your mind off of the idea that somebody
wants to kick your ass
then as the time starts to get closer
you start trying to find ways to calm
yourself i would listen to gospel music
all afternoon god from you that day all
afternoon saturday gospel music yolanda
adams became my favorite artist of all
time
they would come to get me and then it's
it's sad because everybody's hugging you
like all your family like my wife my
children i walk over and i'm kissing my
kids goodbye because they didn't go to
the fights for a long time my nephews
and cousins are like hugging me and then
they say good luck
everybody's like good luck i'm like if
luck has to be involved here i'm in
trouble right
my preparation should dictate what's
gonna happen right
you get to that arena and i'm telling
you every single time i would think to
myself how many times did i go left when
i should have went right to end up here
because you question like god damn this
dude's like a scary dude
and then i would go into the arena i
always snuck back into the arena through
the back so that i can feel the energy
of the crowd just to kind of like
feel that like to before because you
don't want that first burst to be when
you walk through that curtain right
especially last i was like i was the
last guy on
as the champion you're the last fight of
the night the last guy to walk
so this crowd you know i mean you've
been there from fight one to fight 12.
the energy is a bit low but by the main
event that shit's like
right it's played up
and uh
you're back there and you hear your
music and it's like
uh it was like i had a tupac song as i
had to start ride on our enemies when we
ride on our enemies it would play like a
clip of that and then lil wayne right
above it would play and there's a lady
that's like you walk in five four three
and you're on this mark and then you
just
start making it walk and the moment you
hit that curtain and that's why the ufc
does it better than anybody because you
come through the crowd
right like everybody's waving down at
you trying to touch you and the guy's
like walking through that sea of people
[ __ ] what are you thinking about when
you walk through there just like
i always ran i never walked because i
didn't want that moment to like be too
big it's like too much to just take it
all in so i would run i ran to the
octagon every time like not once i've
gotten over the fear now like when you
guys do those stunts like you got to be
scared and once you're like [ __ ] i'm
doing it
you're over it you want to just do it
right so after a point i got i've gotten
over that fear of the moment and i'm
like i'm ready so i'm going to run there
and go and do it so yeah and i would run
and i would run to the outcome and then
i just
walk in there and then they close that
door and there's like a pen they drop
that pin
18 000 20 000 everybody's right the
energy you can feel it going through
your feet and when they drop that pin
you can freaking hear it i can still
hear it wow every time over all that i
can hear that pin pink and i'm like oh
it's going to be him or me now
what's what's the the pin on on the bell
it locks the game
that little clapper for 10 seconds can
you even hear that when you're in there
you can hear it you know it says that
you're a lot actually yeah you can hear
a lot you can hear quite a bit in there
but everything's moving like a thousand
miles a minute do you ever hear any
celebrities yell [ __ ] out you're like
[ __ ] i know that guy all your fighters
so i remember fighting steep and i
looked down in like mgk's right there
i'm like these [ __ ] guys probably
wouldn't sleep
in cleveland
that's what you're thinking about in
there
always walk out to his song too yeah it
was cool right it was a cool thing yeah
yeah
that's cool good experience okay so when
you find out that
that jon jones popped for
performance enhancing drugs yeah like
are you just like
performance enhancing drugs are a real
thing man and you know sometimes these
athletes are testing positive for them
because they're innocently using a
supplement that they think is gonna help
them
but
obviously they're using crappy
supplements if they test positive for
illegal drugs that would never happen
with the greatest supplement in the
world which is athletic greens and baby
i use it every day because it fills in
all of the gaps in my diet and sadly
there are some pretty big gaps in my
diet these days but man
it's like
convenient and comprehensive daily
nutrition in a delicious serving
that has
75
vitamins minerals whole foods sourced
super foods
adaptogens probiotics i'm telling you
this stuff helps your gut health it
helps your brain health
it
just makes you healthy and it's
delicious i use it every day and if you
go to athleticgreens.com
stevo then you're gonna get an entire
year's supply of immune boosting vitamin
d plus five different
pouches with
comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition
i'm telling you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo i use it every day it makes me a
better person now let's talk about jon
jones testing positive
i mean and and what happens that does
that
are you referring does that defeat stay
on your record even though he he broke
the rules so the first time
when he he beat me
uh it was like cocaine right so they
didn't
they didn't suspend him for that
was that the clip that when dana white
went backstage to tell you that was that
no that was ufc 200 that was that was
like the fourth time we were scheduled
to fight you know me and john were
scheduled to fight five times we only
fought twice because some [ __ ] always
kept happening one time i got hurt
then he tested positive for stair for
that was at ufc 200 that's when dana
went back and told you behind
he's like he's like dude can i see you
and i'm like for what
and i was like what do i need to come
over and say you gotta come to the mgm
right now and i was like okay
we're like in the balls of the building
and he's like dude
jones tested positive
i could not believe it i literally was
like
when you lose to someone
all you can think about especially for a
guy like me is to get back to that guy
right so to get back to him i was like
finally and then that happened and then
i fight anderson silva which is crazy
and then um
so then the following year we fought in
anaheim and he beat me
and that and to your question
um
i'd kind of come to terms with it right
like i cried in the octagon like i
remember that yeah and uh and i remember
your explanation after the fact i just
respected it so much he said yeah i
cried because i care that much that much
you know like like if you care about
something that much that that's what
that's what happens and i gotta tell you
i i just remember thinking dude i
respect that so much man thank you that
people don't really like people like so
here's the thing like a lot of people
cry and death right because they love
something so much
you love that person that's not going to
be here anymore
so much that you start to cry and you're
breaking down well with me it was like
losing was like death like that's how
much i hated losing like plus i put
every single bit of my being into
preparing myself to win that fight
so to lose like that and then rogan
asked me he goes
uh dc one of the greatest rivalries it's
not a rivalry if he wins both fights yep
right like even in that were i i was
there i still don't remember like i
don't remember doing the interview i
don't remember i literally don't
remember from when he kicked me until i
woke up like i was in the ambulance and
i was like whoa what the hell i had i
guess i had a concussion it was like
probably seven to ten minutes that i i
will never regain in my life
and uh
i know rogan caught some heat he did but
it's okay though let him do his job like
i'm okay i'm okay with it right so
everybody else should be okay with it
right because i think it showed aside of
me that
it
in my most
beat down moment that's who i am like i
wear my heart on my sleeves and i want
to i want to win
right and so
i go to hawaii
four weeks after like four weeks after
i'm like finally because i don't like i
said i deal with it like that i don't
come outside for like a month i had a
flight back to san jose i drove home i
was like there's no way i could show my
face in the airport i'm embarrassed that
i would let that happen to me so i put
my family in the car my manager drove me
home
uh
i go to hawaii on vacation and i start
seeing dana calling me and like wait for
a while all dana gave was great news hey
yo i'm gonna give you a million dollars
you guys did so well i'm giving you all
this money i'm like okay he did but then
he had started to become the bearer of
bad news and he calls me he goes dc i'm
like yeah
he goes where are you i was like i'm in
hawaii i was like i'm going i'm on
vacation he goes [ __ ]
like what's up it was [ __ ]
he tested positive again and i was like
what
he was like daniel he was like
he tested positive again and
i go so what does this mean
he goes
you're the champion oh look i lost i was
there like i said i was there i lost the
fight of course i was such an idiot yeah
of course that's what happened i said
yeah i go yeah i go i i lost
and he goes
he tested positive on the friday before
so does does that mean that he loses his
purse as well so that that was always my
biggest issue steve because when we were
fighting
i was 30 i mean 2018 17 that would i
would have been
38 years old but the guy's like 10 years
younger than me so every time he tested
positive they would suspend him for a
year but
he's a kid he's like 25 years old you
get a year off with all your money it's
like oh it's only time right it's only
time it's like
it's only time when you have all the
time in the world if i got suspended for
a year at 38 now it's a real problem
because i come back and i'm 39 years old
he comes back he's 28 years old 29 years
old like it was only time and that's
where the biggest issues for me lied in
that whole situation have you guys like
squashed the beef i feel like it's no
it's like rocky and apollo
you still
we don't talk to
is it hard would it be hard calling his
fights
i haven't i haven't called this fight
since wow
i mean will you
i don't know i don't think so do you
purposely not call his fights or he just
hasn't
because i don't want to put myself in a
situation where he can even if i feel
i don't put myself in a situation where
i feel like i have to go too far in one
direction to show that i'm not harboring
bad emotion towards him
for our
situations right don't necessarily i
definitely don't want to be on the
opposite side where i'm [ __ ] on the
guy when he's the guy that's out there
competing so i just think that it's
unfair to not only him but to put myself
in that situation to do that we've got
so many talented uh broadcasters can do
it so i respect that so much yeah um i
mean you guys catch a lot i mean i i
feel like i'm seeing it more and more
frequently
that fighters are like pissed at the
commentators
like saying that you're biased you're
rooting against them and all anyone can
think is like dude
it doesn't change the fact that you lost
the fight you know
yeah tony ferguson was mad at me he's
always he's like you and rogan are going
to [ __ ] on you because i'm like bro
you're saying that we don't talk
positive about you but right you got
beat five rounds against justin gaichy
he hadn't lost he hadn't won a round he
hadn't in a long time you were there
right
the first time in jacksonville with no
people i mean the the you can hear the
punches on tv how crazy were the punches
in person beat him bad bro yeah he and
it changed him forever because remember
he was still on that win streak when he
fought him right right and then he's
shaking his head i'm like oh my god when
he was like
it was just beat down that that was one
that got uh it got called like 10
seconds away from the end of the fight
yeah he just got beat up for 25 minutes
it was hard to watch but it was
different it was like there was nobody
there it was like even now like you go
to the apex there's people there's like
200 people in there and in jacksonville
there was zero people
it was empty and i went to the bathroom
at one point and there was like an usher
there
and i was like yo can i get a hot dog
son he's like
he was just sitting there i was like
what are you doing here he was just a
lone usher just in the [ __ ] dark
sitting there the fighters were walking
out into complete dark me rogan and anak
were eight feet apart with right
glass in front of us it's just the
oddest i could not believe they got
rogan to go there but it's like if dana
asks him he just he goes
was it was it more enjoyable for you
watching those fights with no crowd or
does it the excitement of the crowd
would be actually he sat there
afterwards going
could i say something like what it's not
that bad
it's actually not that bad it adds a
different layer to the fight but then
when we got back in front of fans you're
like okay now
yeah dude that first card with fans was
also in jackson did you go i didn't go
but god was that the best
dude that was the most i got goosebumps
thinking about what was the fight that
was the one
knocked out knocked out
oh yeah and uh oh my god and weidman's
leg was on that card
and uh did wasn't thug rose oh yeah it
was rose number eunice did was that when
she had kicked john wayne
yeah this guy
it's impressive dude he's just on the
callback he actually remembered better
than me i don't even remember all these
fights on the top i'm sitting here
humiliated asking if uh his defeat got
overturned
a long time ago in five years the [ __ ]
was that dude that was the dumbest thing
i've ever said on this podcast five
years ago
you must have said something dumber
right now uh you know what what
what else is is just really really
impressive and notable i think the fact
that
they
your career you were a heavyweight yes
you went down to lightweight for only
one reason yeah because you didn't want
to find yourself competing against cain
velasquez yes
that's [ __ ] unbelievable you know
because when i got to aka kane was the
man right he was on the rise he was
about to become the champion if
you know because you watched it like
there was no one like him i mean
2009 10 11 there was no one like kane
um
and he just helped me as an olympian
that was coming into his gym
not once did he view me as like an enemy
or anything like you see it now with
fighters all the time right amanda has
just left their gym because kayla
harrison started to rise
right i got to number three in the world
and kane still helped me
we were like right on the cusp and when
it was time to renegotiate with the ufc
dana goes he goes
what are you gonna do he goes you're
number three now he goes and there are a
lot of situations where we don't worry
about it he goes you two are too good to
not fight so what are you gonna do and i
was like i'm gonna go down to 205. but
he just asked he was like you guys are
gonna fight he goes we're not we're not
gonna go to keep you away from each
other and then because of that i started
to make my way down it was uh
it was uh it was it was hard but it was
it was good it was a good decision it
made it made for my career to add layers
to it why i mean champ champ yeah
right which is
yeah tomorrow yeah camaro is out for a
year and so that probably hand surgery
yeah so he's out recovering from that so
interim
fight for
kobe covington [ __ ] me up for saying
thumbs up i you know i can't like
i don't even want to say that
but kobe covington's name i it's like i
can't i want to be very careful how i
say his name but who would he fight in
the interim for uh kobe right
that's a tough situation i don't think
they're doing that to him yeah because
camaro's been so active that i think
that you wait for tomorrow even if it's
a year i don't think that
i think that i had heard a rumor
recently that he was looking at like
august now i don't know if he's ready by
august but
if he's looking at august what if it's
september october right like he's still
back again
i i think that the
what kamara just said publicly was that
uh he thinks
anybody who's gonna get a title shot
next has to go through colby covington
and i think that that makes a lot of
sense kobe covington has been 1a for a
long time yeah because who's the killer
man if not if there was no kamarusman
he'd be the champion of the world right
he would be the ch and still talk to
kobe he thinks he won both fights
he got stopped in the first fight
i broke your face
i'm gonna tell you he won both fights
though right um i mean they did the
first one
it was a stoppage so of course he didn't
but if but had it not been a stoppage it
was close to the two
it was a great fight the first fight was
a lot closer and uh you didn't think the
second fight was very close
if it did he won 3-2 on all the cards it
was 48-47 across the board
it just was slower i think that's why
right because covington was a little bit
smarter in his approach that's why he
didn't get hurt as bad but it's like
right it was a bit slower because colby
wasn't pressuring him as much as he did
the first time maybe i'm just thinking
that the first one was just such the
first one was it was the better it was
right yeah um and
did that one
like you can't do an interim there
because
you can't give colby a third title a
shot
well right now
it's it's leon edwards right who has now
been
undefeated in 11 straight fights
the guy has the worst luck he has the
worst luck poor guy yeah and he's a
sweetheart
why wouldn't you have kobe and ian and
and leon leon edwards is so who's
lyanna and hams at no it's leon and
kamaru so leon has now been promised his
title fight okay probably on there was i
am not fighting i'm not smiling but
there's
do not risk it like you have a title
fight against a guy that you've actually
fought before he fought before yeah
that's his last loss last loss was
against him way back in the day yeah and
he's way better since then he's way
better so
it would have to be leon and hamza but
if i'm team edwards i'm going no i'm
going to wait for camaro usman i'm not
because dude think about this you talked
about his luck in like the cove it
happened all this but what about the
nate diaz situation where he beats the
idea
all we talked about afterwards was yo
did you see nate they like rocked his
ass like yeah he gave the story yeah
right oh so they're making nate diaz and
hamzat
pretty safe to say that even your
grandma's heard of nate diaz because
he's that big of a star and you know
what i heard about him is that he rides
a bicycle a hundred miles like it's no
big deal whether he's in training or not
and when i heard that i was intimidated
by the idea but i'm not intimidated of
riding up to 45 miles on a bicycle at up
to 28 miles per hour on a four to six
hour charge
because it's an e-bike and what kind of
e-bike can deliver that performance it's
called electric baby electric e-bikes
and they're the first company to make
e-bikes affordable and i'm telling you
the tribe has spoken man because this is
like the most popular and most
environmentally friendly way better than
a car
gets it back on the bike man get in
shape telling you it's 799
bucks these bikes are starting from it's
the most affordable perhaps the only
affordable e-bike on the market and if
you go to electric
ebikes.com that's l e c t r i c
e b i k e s dot com
use the promo code stevo then they will
gift you
a free
folding mountable bike lock for your
electric e-bike i use them i
love hauling ass on those things my
buddy poopies and i we uh we jousted
with them had a blast and i'm telling
you join the revolution because they're
saving the world and you know i love
companies that save the world so go to
electric ebikes.com use the promo code
stevo jump on that deal jump on that
bike and save the world now let's get
back to it
that's what we saw that's what we saw on
on the right on the war room wall oh my
god ryan clark my guy with that does the
ef show me i got this show called the
pivot what uh fred taylor and chan and
chan and crowder and they interviewed
dana and somehow they get the match-up
wall
like the ufc is usually pretty good
about making sure you don't get the
match-up wall i don't know how they did
that but i think because of that now
that fight's gonna be like it's in
trouble oh yeah well because i think it
was like kind of not done
right right right so and then so that
gives the fighters a lot of leverage and
their managers going absolutely believe
that it should be nate diaz and conor
mcgregor
oh yeah it should be nate and connor
finish the trilogy especially if nate's
about once right right right but then
are you gonna have michael chandler and
connor is that just talking [ __ ] i did
this thing the other day where i said i
know who he should fight but i know who
he's going to fight he should fight nate
he's going to fight chandler
that that doesn't make sense to me i i
think that you're right he should fight
nate and i just think both of them are
are on skids yes you know like uh
connor is such a cash cow for the ufc
like why send him in there to a fight
he's going to lose i think chandler i
think i think chandler's tough fight but
chandler is willing to engage with him
on his terms
and if you know conor if you're going to
stand with him he has a chance
right right so but the weight different
is well i guess mcconnell is pretty big
now connor wants him to fight him at 70.
see chandler's smart
because chandler called him out in the
octagon afterwards there was only you're
there
and uh
but he called him out at 170. so he put
a little bit of sprinkle over the top of
that ice cream sundae right hey i'll
fight you but i'll also fight you up if
you want me to fight you up
right and uh
that that bones well for conor because
like
he fought cowboy at 170. he did and and
and then shoulder bumped him right right
right and and cowboy's a natural
lightweight yes he's a lightweight chip
chad like natural lightweight so he's
fighting that 170 but fighting
lightweights up a weight loss
video
is a natural light but it seems like
he's gotten bigger and i would not want
to see connor versus mazda doll that's a
bad matchup
mazda dolls that dude can box like i
know usually knocked him silly but he
can box like maybe was able to knock him
out because he was worried about to take
the takedowns too and getting clinched
because in the first fight he got like
so stymied with the clinch that he was a
little bit but i mean he got hit hard
and he got hit hard yeah he got hit hard
and that's big and then you can see that
because they poured water on his head
and he's is that was is there any merit
to that dude anytime i got rocked
i'm like pour water pour out of my face
like pour the cold water to like try to
bring me back right every time i would
do it to rock hold when rockhold was
fighting chris weidman he was like
exhausted so i'm like splashing this ice
cold water on his head and like rubbing
it in his head to try to like help you
recoup because cold water does something
to you when it like it shocks you a
little bit yeah now we got rock called
acosta coming up yeah yeah he wants
costa he wants that fight yeah he i was
like this i was like why i was like this
dude's like powerful like you've been
knocked out like
he's like i'm gonna kill him he's like
i'm gonna kill him i know i can kill him
you know beat his dude
what was that situation with paulo costa
and they kept changing the [ __ ]
weight
it where's like
he's can't make weight he was so big he
was like he showed up to the
fight week i think he was like 210
pounds yeah and victoria was just cool
without he fighting 186. i mean you all
romero would be a good matchup right
acosta
rose
um but uh but dude like victoria like
how cool was victoria about that like
yeah i'll do it oh because so now we're
going up to catch it oh now we're at
lightweight
light heavyweight but tori just was like
i want the fight but like that's crazy
because victoria's not like a cool guy
like victoria's not like cool about
anything he's always mad
marvin's like the maddest human being
you've ever met in your life he's like
he's like mad about everything you can't
say don't say anything about him on your
podcast because then he's going to get
you right he said he's just like a mad
angry guy he was mad at me for not
putting him in the video game for a long
time he's like dc put him in the game
wow i'm like marvin i don't this this is
not a singular decision there's a
company called ea sports right call them
like i don't just say hey i want marvin
vettori the game but he's like mad like
so but he's actually sweetheart face to
face but he was like you know he thought
that i i was unfair to him when i called
this fight without a sign he was like
right like marvin's that guy right so
for him the way he handled that was i
was there for that one and [ __ ] and
i i thought
that vittori
was going to be able to to take down out
of sonia and hold him there not even
close he got [ __ ] made
thought out in his like post conference
after man bro he's like got this star
quality about him now he is
like he pushes it a little bit hard with
uh
you know that the overconfidence but
that's the fight game yeah it's full
that's yeah you have to be like that
maybe yeah but you don't you don't have
to be like super again he doesn't play
it in the middle but he's confident but
like when he got paul acosta and costa
falls face down and he like jumps behind
him like let me come on dude like don't
do them like that
you don't do them like that man it's
better than what mazda did to uh than to
ask the aspirin that was not necessary
yeah but then i mean like that thrill
that comes to you after you [ __ ] win
is like how do you express that like
dana why was giving michael chandler's
shift for doing backflips he's like
enough of the backwards he did four
yeah yeah and one does it but like what
do you do i mean all that it comes to
you you're like you have to like express
yourself you're just like going crazy
yeah
here's something one thing about chan
little that i was surprised he didn't do
any follow-up shots which is right the
him for him to be able to control
himself in that moment because like when
you get a guy down you jump one over you
start pounding their faces
that was the most vicious night if ever
there was one to not follow up
like but i mean he was the remember when
rhonda when holly holm kicked ronda and
then she like jumped on rhonda's like
this and hollywood right
yeah yeah i mean that's the thing man
these follow-up shots like
i
i can't help but but feel like man
what what is it in a person that can
that makes it possible like like there's
something it's disturbing when someone's
completely unconscious and you're just
trying to punch me because you're you're
just like trained right
i did it in practice one time the guy
the guy that was in practice like he was
like he was training with this he was in
my weight but we weren't gonna fight but
we were training and i was like first
time at the gym i gotta really show this
dude that he can't come in here and beat
me so i hit him with a shot to the body
and he fell down and i jumped on him to
finish him and bob's like daniel you
crazy son of a [ __ ] everybody's like
opening the cage they keep it threw me
down off of him i was like finishing the
dude man it gets crazy in that gym man
and then there's other times too when i
think
especially like early in the card when
there's not that many people there but
so it's like so calm of a you know but
but one guy will get the better of the
other guy and the other guy he's hurt
and then swarming on him and then the
place turns into like some kind of roman
coliseum and i'm just like i just i i
have this feeling come over me like
what's wrong with me
crazy like you're crazy that's why we
look that's why we watch jackass right
reality is we kind of want to see you
guys get hurt
is somebody going to get hurt like it's
like
how far can these guys push it before
they get hurt right it's the same as
like when there's an accident in the
road and everybody's everybody even
grandma everybody stops yeah and we
watch it on tv you see like random [ __ ]
on youtube you're like watching
uh
bear attacks or like lion attacks
somebody's getting bit by a freaking dog
like you're like oh my god this is crazy
yeah i was like you watch it it's like
that's who we are we like we're like
drawn to it from the olden days when
they stuck people in there with those
swords in the colosseum and they were
chilling lions with the lions yeah and
they were always it was the most
exciting day that he would have been at
the prelims for those fights
celebrity shot at the very beginning of
the night so when he goes up there it's
like nope wow he was there since this
morning seven hours takes commitment i'm
like i'm like texting seven hours i'm
like texting him a question and he's
like sending me a picture of the fight
i'm like
i need it's the prelims dude
i don't even care dude like yeah he's
he's in i like doing that those things
how many of those guys that you see at
the beginning you're like yo this dude's
in the main event i remember when i saw
this dude on the prelims yeah how many
have you remember any of them like that
ah
i mean dude
was it uh kevin holland i think i was in
the apex on his contender series see
like that and then all of a sudden he
goes on that massive run in 2020 you're
like wow i've seen this dude's whole
journey right
yeah it's awesome i liked when they put
cowboy in the prelims i mean that made
sense
they put him in a fight before the main
event yeah it's a it's the prelim main
event right so that's like
the future
if you want to be if you're going to be
on the prelim you want to be the very
last one
because that's the name that's supposed
to propel you into buying the
pay-per-view if you're on the fence yeah
you get to see a familiar name like
cowboy yeah fight me for free i'm gonna
go see if they if he's here then what do
they have on that pay-per-view right to
make sure that he's here but dude more
and more like i i remember uh
turning on the fight pass prelims on
on some pay-per-view night
and it was like all ranked fighters yeah
on the fight past pre-labs
dude and i remember when um
when darren till was fighting against um
tyron woodley in dallas oh god that was
a great one arena all donna i think was
that was like one of the fight pass
prelims and uh my girl and i show up for
the very first fight
right we flew to dallas just for that we
sit down for the very first fight and
anthony kievis is already in his
he doesn't miss either
anthony kiedis the red hot chili peppers
man he is the gnarliest fan i remember
thinking too i'm like i'm okay i'm just
sitting down next to anthony keaton's
right here you know and
i'm not gonna bug the guy i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna annoy the guy i'm just
gonna shut up my own business you know
as soon as i sit down he's like hey wait
what do you think it is
that's his deal dude yeah we were just
hanging out talking
dude six [ __ ] hours six straight
hours we sat there just shooting [ __ ]
talking fighting with anthony you met
him before that and then it's like he's
like i've never met him before that no
never met him and it's like you think
like this dude's a red hot chili pepper
is like i'm just uh
that's crazy we went to
me and my wife were in
brooklyn i think when nate diaz fought
connor yeah so
my seat is right next to connor's family
which is so unfortunate because you
can't cheer it's like
if you're rooting for that you can't
cheer you're just kind of stuck me my
wife
who doesn't give a [ __ ] she's like she
likes she doesn't see if she likes nate
she likes nate so she's like i'm
cheering regardless
but i sit next to gordon ramsay
i've been watching hell's kitchen my
whole life right and he's like hey dc dc
so i'm like all right so so i make a
conscious decision that i'm about to
answer every question that gordon ramsey
asked me if by chance he asked more than
one so he continues to ask
man i want to go to hell's kitchen in
vegas i'm like
i got gordon ramsay's number i'm a texas
dude so it paid off that was the payoff
i answered all the fight questions yes
he got me in the hell's kitchen
and guess what the beef wellington is
not that good he'd be pissed off oh
really
that's his special condition
i get beef wellington because of gordon
ramsay do you like it
[Laughter]
would he be pissed about the beef
wellington or would he be pissing you
for saying that no no let me pick that
because you know when they make the beef
wellington it's just signature dish he
wants it great yeah they did the one i
had was not great he would say you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
these probably
probably
that's how you're supposed to taste yeah
it's not supposed to taste like your
burnt ass barbecue
he goes at it with people yeah he's the
man though he's the man you're not
eating the beef wellington when you're
trying to fight that light heavyweight
no well i have i have nutrition saying i
have guys that live in my house cook
every meal they watch everything when i
was making light everywhere when you're
done with making weight and the fight's
over what's your go-to meal
so it was a very difficult thing because
initially we could take ivs and then
they banned them they banned ivs saying
that you could hide steroids or
something in the iv i don't know what
the hell they were talking about i was
like i just want the iv so that i don't
[ __ ] myself for two hours after making
weight because the moment you have been
that dehydrated you eat and drinking
everything wants to come right back out
of you you're like sick it upsets your
stomach but if you take the iv all the
fluid goes directly
into your body instead of through the
belly so then you're like fine but once
they banned that i had this like we had
these three drinks uh from my
nutritionist
it was one was like the first it was
like these essential waters they're like
this big
drink that one
uh it's like i think it's a lead and a
half i don't know how big they are but
like uh it was all it was so salty and
gross
and then the second one was less salt
with a little bit of a protein so it
tasted a little better and the third one
was all the sugars so it was like super
sweet and good but before i could eat
anything i had to make sure i got down
all that it was like a gallon of fluids
to make sure that i didn't have all that
runny stomach but then after that i
would uh i would have these massive
dinners on friday night with all my
family and we i'd eat steak every time
because that's what you're going on like
you're not going on the meal at 4pm on
saturday
you're going on that food from the night
before that you digest and it's in your
system and that's what you're getting
yes that's what you're going to fight on
um i i had an idea
that uh i asked chuck liddell about and
he he thinks it's a great idea yeah when
you're at the uh
what do you call it like the check-in
the prep point the prep point they're
putting the vaseline on your face you
know like uh
why not have that prep point be
an an actual scale it wouldn't add any
time but then you could then then you
would know how much weight the fighter
put back on since weighing in
i don't want to know what i weigh i want
to just go out there what if you're
heavy like what if dude one time it was
bad
so you got to manage the weight down so
like when i would fight at 205 i would
work hard to get to like 225 and then
train there for like a month
then so i'd never get back over 222 223
on fight night well when i fought rumble
johnson like there's a bit of a night
oh my god i always have to address this
there's a bit of a false
idea that i grabbed the towel to make
the wall okay
[Music]
didn't i didn't put it i mean
i was dehydrated i needed something to
help me get up onto the scale then i
took my hands off but um
anyways i didn't manage my weight as
well that time so i was heavy i was like
2 30 coming down
when i stepped into the scale to fight
rumble i weighed 234 pounds
could not believe that i gained almost
30 pounds overnight wow i felt like just
bloated fat terrible when i was in shape
i would fight around 222 223 but a lot
of times like i wouldn't want to get on
the scale because i knew i'd be like
what if i'm heavy and that kind of
played a little bit of a trick on me
when i when i went in there that night
but that's really interesting that
you're saying that like you don't want
to know but as a fan wouldn't you be
fascinated to know how much that
everybody could learn a lot
yeah like i mean lester chandler said he
weighed 173 pounds when he stepped into
the octagon with tony ferguson 17 pounds
he looks huge though he looked huge
right so so if if you just like
if if you're if you're dana yeah if
you're
the boss then and you think man that
might be something that's compelling
that would would be like
interesting to the fans that they would
enjoy it would add entertainment yeah
then would you think put a scale at the
check-in
i mean you could put the scale of the
chicken but
i just don't know if you
what if like a heavyweight 300 pounds
295 like seriously that's that's
interesting so you think you think put a
scale at the prep point they step on to
get all that on but it's just not gonna
be right weights right because the guy
they're touching you they're it meant so
if they do by chance touch you it could
affect the weight shown on the scale
right but so you don't want to really be
touching anything when you're on the
scale even though i only especially a
tower yeah i only touched it in order to
get myself up there yeah you don't want
to really be touching anything it might
mess with the scale i
love that so much all right well i mean
dude i i i
i think just a question that i that i
got to ask more people and i'm probably
because i've never heard anybody else
suggest that no yeah it's different and
and i don't think it would ever like
it's not like changing the judging or
open scoring it's just it's just a piece
of information
like another thing i think would i think
you should always have
live odds be part of every beginning of
the round the live odds only happen see
so the live odds can almost be viewed a
little bit like open scoring right
because they're telling you who they
think is winning right right so that
might be a nice little medium for
instead of going all the way to open
score and show the live odds now i don't
disagree with that i i mean i like
because
some so randomly like we'll ask anik
like what are the live odds and he'll
say it yeah
but i think that's just because you love
this [ __ ] so much it's like you want to
know everything about it like right
i think uh
i mean
sometimes they'll they'll say oh the
live odds have changed this way yeah i
mean like like it's it's it's uh
mandatory always
you see the what the odds are like the
end of the fight i like that one i like
that one a little yeah more than the
scale but i like that one a lot that was
actually that was that's a good idea
i'll run that by my guy the producer
dude did you know that um
that um
when uh
we went over to to espn from fox yeah
that
i'm
it's saturday nights that fight but i
got my tour i'm like i'm on stage doing
my shows on tour so i gotta wait until i
get back to the hotel and then i watch
it on the video on demand but but but i
i go to espn plus to the video on demand
after the fights already happened and
the thumbnails got the person who won
the
celebrating and i'm like dude the only
reason the only reason i'm going to to
this [ __ ] page is because i want to
watch the fights because i haven't seen
them yeah but i don't want to know i
don't want spoilers he would call me
into the room to push the button so he
didn't have to look at it
yeah and and dude i went off man i like
i i dm dean i was like dana dude i'm
[ __ ] like uh what the [ __ ]
and and dana says uh i sent your uh you
know i i i sent your message to the
president of espn and the number two at
disney
and and they're on it and ever since
then they don't do that
that's amazing that is actually amazing
have you talked to the ufc at all steve
about like doing something some kind of
commentating some kind of pre-fight
post-fight interview commentating on a
fight dude these guys are are absolutely
sure not coming to snoop cast a little
bit ago that was fun yeah um i think
that there's something and and uh
i'm talking to a couple people about
some kind of original programming for
ufc fight pass yeah that makes sense
yeah you know some kind of a of a of a
show that doesn't interfere with the
actual
events could you imagine being a part of
the show i think that's honestly what's
saving me and this thing and all the
guys now that are retiring that's what's
saving us right we're still a part of
the show yeah yeah you don't miss
anything like people are still going hey
dc do you see picture picture
it's the same right so you don't you
just don't get to feel the rush of the
fight
dude were you coming i'm sorry go ahead
just on a flight to hawaii i had to text
bisping i i sent him this text i said
dude like
i've gotta thank you because on this
flight to hawaii on the american
airlines video on demand they got your
biz being documentary was it good
it is [ __ ] fantastic really
yeah it opens up and it's like the
[ __ ] universal like a full like dude
it's such a great production man and i'm
so happy for him yeah he's doing good
this thing is doing his books really
good no one in the world has had a
career turnaround like michael bisping
like the dude [ __ ] became the
champion with one eye and became the
good guy kind of do you remember like
when he fought dan henderson how bad you
wanted him to get beat
god i want this little british son of a
gun to get beat so bad it didn't get
starchy like yes but then at the end
you're kind of like
mad because he knocked out luke and i'm
like god he just knocked out my boy but
everything he's drinking everybody like
but if it's gonna be anybody right kind
of happy for bisping it's like it was a
weird thing you know like what are you
drinking the press conference talking
[ __ ] more [ __ ]
yeah
las vegas
i love him so much and you know i love
too
that when you guys are calling fights
the way that
like i i just think that you handle the
balance of like just hanging out having
a good time being like serious analysts
[ __ ] with each other a little bit
joking around like not taking it too
seriously but not you know yeah for sure
and he's you guys are so [ __ ] funny
particularly bisping bisping's out of
his mind
he says anything bro sometimes like we'd
be at fox working together and like we'd
be off air but you know the camera the
like the speakers are all it's always on
yeah so he's saying crazy [ __ ] i'm like
yo chill you're gonna get fired and then
you're gonna get me fired with you
like you're gonna thank both of us and
our families if you don't stop acting
like michael bisping right now dad
you're you're sorry to cut you off but
uh you're a fan of wrestling craig oh
yeah
wait wait what no no no no no no no no
but www
but you're a fan of uh like wrestling
and and the theatrics of it do you think
that like the trash talking the [ __ ]
talking is a good thing for ufc
or because i saw i saw an article saying
that it's hurting the ufc but it's not i
think i think it's helping it you know
and i just want to know your take
because when you went in there with
brock lesnar that was entertaining it
was amazing
oh we did not get the payoff we just
didn't get the payoff when he shoved you
after you fought stipe yeah and took
that moment from you and [ __ ] shoved
you like that i was not [ __ ] happy
with brian mike did you see my coach
push him my coach is like five three he
runs for pushes bro there's like what
are you doing i think after he pushed
back he realized oh [ __ ] i just pushed
brock lesnar brock like looked over at
him he panicked but um
it was like it was like a made for tv
moment like him coming in there and all
that like
and uh we just didn't get to fight
because like but i mean it was like i
mean talk about a ped guy
oh my god
no problem
i'm gonna be mad at john i'm like i'm
like trying to sign up
have you ever met brock i i haven't but
uh so nice what is he like six five
three hundred huge he's massive and bro
like the sweetest person you've ever met
for sure unbelievable we went to we went
to so we we go to uh hell in the cell
here in los angeles a while back me and
my wife and my children what's held in
this cell
undertaker brock at los angeles it was
at the uh the crypto dot com arena now
and uh
so it's a wwe event www event okay brock
walks out then the other team comes up
selena goes who's that oh man i go yo
it's the undertaker she's like that's
the undertaker she was like how old is
he now i was like
in his 50s he's got to be in his 50s
they wrestle we go in the back rock
takes photos with my children as we're
driving home because my kids at school
in the morning ended late uh brock calls
on the phone and he's like little daniel
did you enjoy it and he's like telling
me he's like i'm four drinks down
already you know i'm feeling good
he's the nicest dude bro like you would
never imagine it once you know brock
lesnar you know brock lesnar like when i
fought jones at ufc 200
uh
it broke that he was going to be
fighting i was like yo
i heard rumors i go are you fighting
and he goes he didn't tell me
and then when they broke that he's
fighting he goes he texts me
merry christmas [ __ ] you know he
yeah paper pieces are gonna be so
running through the roof now right right
he got a brock lesnar christmas that's
what he told me right now just like he's
a sweetheart of a guy man did you see
him throw wee man through the table dude
i love i love like i love this is
something that you and i are going to
talk about on my podcast but i love when
you guys do the wwe [ __ ]
crazy and uh
it's crazy
it's wild man it's wild
you have to take bumps like that's crazy
taking bumps
it hurts yeah i did
i i got beat into a blackout yeah
against umaga
yeah i don't remember leaving the ring
that was me with jones yeah the same
thing my head
do you remember coming too at a certain
point during that
uh i remember coming to in like the
control room
of the [ __ ] you know and not even
coming too because you're walking around
like i just don't remember leaving the
ring yeah they didn't even show me leave
the ring on the broadcast it just got
[ __ ] dark
they just like went to the graphic comes
over he's oh he's still i can drop it oh
my god did you talk to him after that at
all i did and he was cool man he was
super cool um
what uh
i may do we should we should wrap it up
and do your podcast but um
you're in pretty good like
i know that you had like knee surgery
and [ __ ] yeah yeah like uh like how's
your overall health good my back is my
back's jacked really bad like that's how
i knew it was kind of over i should have
stopped after i beat derrick lewis in
new york city um
i woke up on fight day and i was going
to go for my morning run and i sneezed
and i threw my back out oh i was like
okay i'm too old to be doing this now
right like i sneezed
i like i was like okay so yeah i'm i'm
[ __ ] up like this yeah it's pretty
much over and so
uh the ufc literally like pieced me
together enough to go and fight that
night but the reality was i knew he
couldn't wrestle
so i was like
i can beat this dude even if i'm not
great yeah because he can't wrestle so i
was able to go out there and beat him i
should have stopped i shouldn't have
because then i had back surgery like a
month later when you have back surgery
it's
yeah you're done yeah you're done i got
old man i i think i still believe to
this day if i fought stipe miocic in my
30s mid 30s i would have beat him every
time just in terms of skills
i think that guy would have beat him
jones
i didn't right like and i was in my like
as prime as i could be right he beat me
at 36 and he beat me at 38 or 30 at 38
so i was still physically
pretty good was jones going to fight
stipe is that the this might be the
fight that's going to happen i'm talking
about it but i mean dude if they do an
interim title
it it needs to be those two yeah it
really does it should be jones's teepee
yeah
that way yeah that that that makes all
the scenes you're gonna go
i mean i'll sit next to you because i'm
not gonna call the fight
who do you think wins that
i mean
i think they just already got odds on it
and it's charged i think jones i think
jones beats me
yeah
because honestly i think stipe is a
fantastic champion a great fighter but
being in there with him three times like
i just feel like if i wasn't
40
and you know i beat him at 39 40 and 41.
i feel like if i wasn't 39 40 and 41
yeah it would not have been the most
difficult fight for me he stephen beat
and ganu on that first fight against in
goner because then goneri didn't know
how to wrestle did not arrest and jones
does know how to wrestle plus jones can
stay from you know from that range and
pick him apart with his length
and uh and so yeah that's why you're
going to have the odds in favor of jones
is jones not like pretty out of practice
i mean obviously he's not practicing
he's really difficult to figure out
because he's so big and long no
heavyweight all those advantages will be
less pronounced because right i mean i'm
5 10. right he's 6'4 yeah with an 84
inch reach so for me to get to him i got
to go through a lot just to get into
range right that's with anybody anybody
but but when you got a guy that has
those tools
with that range
it makes them more difficult so i think
that that's where that's where people
have struggled i think that's why you
also took a break right because those
guys are starting to kind of figure out
a path right because he's not the most
aggressive guy
right so if you play it a little bit
slower he was right in the beginning
right yeah but as he started to fight
those big dudes like like anthony smith
uh
the brazilian guy um oh uh thiago thiago
yeah
those big dudes were just like okay
standing out there just kind of flicking
kicks and not really like engaging with
him because they didn't have to
and so he got really really close and he
said you know what i'm gonna now i can
go to heavyweight because the victories
at light heavyweight are becoming super
difficult because these guys have kind
of figured out how to fight me right
yeah i mean dude
you met him yeah i mean like i got uh i
was doing a show in albuquerque and and
they they uh
the the
venue manager says hey jon jones is here
wants to meet you she said [ __ ] yeah
you're coming back you know
and uh i uh you know like
he watched my show it was super nice
and uh and then
some time after that it was right when
he came up with this care project now
he's gonna like change and he's like hey
like come out to albuquerque and i'm
saying [ __ ] it you know i got there we
kind of became buddies and at a certain
point he just
went dark on me you know like and i
couldn't figure it out like uh
you know that and so i don't know what
his deal is and it's like you know yeah
certain that's how it is like i thought
that's how i with stone cold steve
austin like we'll be like talking for a
lot like we're in then it just it just
takes a lot of talk again it's not even
like that though i don't know i think
that
i i i don't know man i'm not even sure
what happened
but uh
i i
because
i was doing this thing i was trying to
get cauliflower here
you know
you know what i'll tell you that i'll
tell that story in your podcast okay
you're uh you're we'll tell that story
on your podcast so right now we can take
all of the people who are listening to
this and send them to the dc podcast and
how new is it this is the first episode
the first time i'm not doing it unless i
i said i want to do with stevo
i said i want my guys the very first so
it's not the first thing on my channel
but it's the first time i'm doing this
particularly yeah i'm excited
unbelievable like i'm so grateful for
for what this podcast has done
just for me man it's it's fun
like talk to super interesting people
every week and it makes like real money
it yeah my shows you know like i got
like it's just done great things so
everybody i'm gonna say [ __ ] for the
youtube people click here yep daniel
cormier
dot com youtube.com
daniel dc cormier there it is right and
subscribe
give my boy tell all your people come
follow you all yeah come on give me boy
a like over here yeah
that's right man everyone [ __ ] check
out me in dc on unfast multifaceted
multi-faceted multi-faceted all right
dude thank you let's go that was awesome
my beloved street team you might have
noticed that for those of you watching
on youtube nothing popped up on the
screen when i said click here maybe
nothing's going to pop up
because dc hasn't put his podcast out
yet but when he does baby it's going to
be right here
so i don't want to chew up more than 20
seconds
that but thank you and
give dc some love if you would
bye bye guys oh and we're number one on
netflix